[музика]
вітаємо це програма У фокусі Європа я
Лара бабалола Ласкаво просимо війна
Росії в Україні серйозно вплинула на
енергопостачання Європи і змусила країни
шукати альтернативи що пережити зиму
безпека трубопроводів та електромереж
також має важливе значення саме тому
диверсія на газопроводі північний потік
у вересні Минулого року занепокоїла
європейські уряди вибухи зруйнували
частини підводних газових труб що
пролягають між Росією та Німеччиною
стався витік газу у Балтійському морі то
стоїть за цими атаками досі не з'ясовано
коли російський природний газ без
перешкодно надходив до Європи Норвегія
була невеликим гравцем на ринку експорту
газу але після того як Москва почала
перекривати постачання Норвегія стала
найбільшим європейським постачальником
блакитного палива це змушує військових
Норвегії бути у стані підвищеної
готовності війська були Розгорнуті для
захисту норвезьких енергетичних систем і
газопроводів у північному морі рони
Андерсен очолює військово-морський флот
країни його місія гарантувати що не буде
ніяких перешкод і газ потрапить туди де
він потрібен
командувач норвезького флоту руне
Андерсен інспектує Фрегат пришвартований
на західному узбережжі Норвегії
такі кораблі стежать за територіальними
водами Норвегії та перш за все за тим що
лежить на їхньому морському дні нафту і
газупроводами необхідними для
забезпечення багатьох європейських країн
Ми не можемо контролювати все що
відбувається під водою
але Інформація що надається виробниками
енергоносіїв у поєднанні із даними
військовий розвідки дає нам доволі
детальне уявлення про мережу
трубопроводів розташовану нижче
Норвегія має захищати Близько 9 тисяч
кілометрів підводних трубопроводів і
кабелів і крім того нафтові газові
установки в морі і на суходолі норвезькі
військові несуть цілодобовий
патрулювання страх став більш реальним
після того як у вересні Минулого року
були підірвані частини газопроводу
Північний потік Норвегія також
наражається на небезпеку саме тому в
жовтні Минулого року прем'єр-міністр
Норвегії юнац гарстіоре заявив що
норвезькі збройні сили підвищили свою
обороноздатність Ми повинні очікувати
загроз по всій країні
на мо в повітрі та в інтернеті
саме тому ми повинні підвищувати
обороноздатність нашої країни
експерт з питань безпеки
столиріксан вважає що норвежці були
наївними він роками попереджав що Росія
завжди тримала сусідню Норвегію В полі
зору
візьмемо наприклад велику кількість
російських громадян які працюють у
норвезьких судноплавних компаніях навіть
у прибережному судноплавстві
Хоча всі знають що це цілеспрямована
спроба російського уряду проникнути в
країну
зараз нам потрібно комплексна концепція
безпеки яка б враховувала військові
загрози а також тероризм і шпигунство
у жовтні Минулого року у північному
місті тронсе був заарештований чоловік
який назвався бразильським вченим
пізніше дослідницька група
заявила що він був полковником
російської військової розвідки Геру
і спочатку війни Росії в Україні
норвезька поліція заарештувала 9
російських туристів у різних місцях
серед них сина одного російського
олігарха під час морського туру його
звинуватили у незаконному запуску дрона
та фотографуванні заборонених зон
але багатьох пересічних норвежців це не
надто турбує
деякі люди постійно підозрюють
шпигунства я ставлюся до цього скептично
але я не маю нічого проти того щоб армію
підвищили свою боєготовність
Росія намагаються налякати нас такими
діями
Але ми не повинні цього допустити
однак норвезький флот не хоче щоб його
застали зненацька головна командувач ВМС
Норвегії руни Андерсен звернувся до
берегової охорони з проханням звітувати
про стан справ норвезькі військові
посилили патрулювання вздовж більш ніж
двох із половиною тисяч кілометрів
узбережжя наш підхід дуже гнучкий
Ми не можемо бути всюди одночасно
ми вирішуємо іноді протягом години куди
йти І коли
настрій військових дуже серйозний але
також приємно усвідомлювати що робота
для якої нас тренували і готували стали
важливішою ніж будь-коли
Норвегія зараз найбільший постачальник
газу в
Європі країни але з ним пов’язаний
велика відповідальність командувач ВМС
рони Андерсен та його підлеглі
намагаються забезпечити доставку газу
туди де він потрібен особливо в цій
неспокійні часи
ще один наслідок рішення президента
Росії Володимира Путіна про вторгнення в
Україну збільшився попит на деревину У
польських Карпатських лісах процвітає
деревообробна промисловість
держава виділила дерева для вирубки для
перетворення на брикети цей план
занепокоє в екологічних активістів у
лісі багато дерев яким сотні років бурі
ведмеді використовують їх як барлоги
йозефіна і як оброблять усе можливе щоб
зберегти ліс і забезпечити ведмедя
спокійне життя
тут у лісах Південної Польщі ведмеді
досі можуть почуватися як удома
високі старі дерева дають ведмедям
притулок і захист але зараз ліс став
джерелом конфліктів юзефіна і Якуб
захисники природи вони проводять
інвентаризацію старих дерев такі високі
як ці помічені для вирубки що може мати
серйозні наслідки тварини мають де
сховатися Спочатку це можуть бути
маленькі тварини наприклад лисиця а
згодом розщелено може стати ще більшою і
в ній може оселитися Ведмідь
червоною крапкою відмічено дерево яке
підлягає вирубці це рішення польської
лісової адміністрації ці дерева стоять
не на території заповідника і це
проблема для ведмедів інтереси лісу
заготівельників тут у пріоритеті це
обмежує простір де ведмеді можуть
спокійно жити Лісова адміністрація
закликає відвідувачів не підходити надто
близько до тварин але це все одно
трапляється вкрай рідко в управлінням є
експозиція під відкритим небом де
представлено багато місцевих лісових
тварин за винятком ведмедя спеціальний
захист для ведмедів не потрібен каже
речник регіонального управління лісового
господарства
тут у 1950 році
записки до 1970-х тут було 20 ведмедів А
зараз 200
Це доволі значний приріст
польські органи лісового господарства
більше зосереджені на лісозаготівлях
через війну Росії в Україні ціни на
деревину високі а паливних матеріалів не
вистачає
але захисники лісу не зовсім у цьому
переконанні
у цьому дереві ймовірно близько шести чи
семи кубометрів деревини
зовнішніми цілими це від одного до двох
тисяч євро за одне дерево тож це не такі
вже і великі гроші
Мені би губимо нашого національного
спадщину за ненатою великі гроші
Якщо час від часу робить кілька дерев
які варто захисту
тих що можуть вважатися пам'ятками
природи
навряд чи буде помітною
навид позикає кільку чи кількох років
ведмеді використовують такі старі дерева
як барліг тому що вони трухляві і мають
розщелене молоді нову посаджені дерева
не дуже допомагають у цьому сенсі
для цього потрібно щоб дерево було
порожнє всередині але воно встає таким з
віком тож якщо ми дозволимо цьому дереву
такому типу дереву залишиться в лісі то
для ведмедів буде більше вільних місць
якщо ми зрубаємо їх усіх щоб продати на
деревину то ведмедям більше не буде де
жити
немає
глибоко у лісі далеко від цивілізації
тільки лісових активістів розбили
протестний табір виступаючи проти
лісорубів
не всі задоволені їхніми протестами
на машину що стояли біля табору було
скоєно напад і конфлікт загострюється
лісові активісти живуть не в цьому
регіоні А у Варшаві чи інших великих
містах
Якуб юзефіна і Рафал не мають наміру
відступати
і він зніщення яке постемпують хоча
хтось відбуваються масове знищення
я не можу з цим миритися
так то заставки Я хочу що моя донька
могла насолоджуватися цими старими
лісами в майбутньому
[музика]
і можливо навіть побачити ведмедів
Звісно якщо всі старі дерева будуть
вирубані тварини підуть кудись в інше
місце вони можуть навіть зайти в райони
населені людьми що може бути небезпечним
це стало проблеми в останні десятиліття
усе частіше трапляються інциденти з
ведмедями коли люди отримують травми
одна людина навіть загинула
люди і тварини цього регіону мають одну
спільну рису вони соромляться камер
багато людей тут працюють у Лісовій
промисловості на табличках вони не
приховують свого ставлення до активістів
вони еко-терористи
але йозефіна і Якуб вважають що багато
людей не усвідомлюють наскільки тісний
зв'язок між ведмедями і деревами
ви можете легко уявити як ведмідь тобто
велика тварина вагою 200 кг може
поміститися в дереві
ми зараз але в майбутньому що дерево
стане порожнистом Я думаю ціла сім'я
ведмедів зможе поміститися
Вони часто просили владу взяти під
охорону старі трухляві дерева прохання у
яких майже завжди відмовляли
сила позитивного мислення дослідження
показують що воно може продовжити
тривалість життя людини навіть з міцнити
імунну систему Для когось збереження
здорового світогляду стає викликом для
когось це здається неможливим Стефан
кампіони з Бельгії страждає від депресій
негативна самооцінка занепад сили втрата
інтересу поширені симптоми хвороби зараз
у столиці Бельгії Брюсселі стартував
пілотний проект та спрямований на
допомогу таким людям як Стефан лікарі
прописують пацієнтам похід до музею і це
щось більше ніж просто споглядання
картин та артефактів
депресія темне місце Стефан кампіон який
страждає від депресії вже довгий час
знає як важко впоратись із повсякденним
життям
одягатися і виходити на вулицю бачите з
іншими людьми важко їздити в транспорті
але сьогодні кампіон отримує новий
рецепт від свого терапевта він і доктор
Вінсент алютіжє одні з тих хто бере
участь у шестимісячному пілотному
проекті пацієнтами з депресією виписують
рецепти на відвідування п'яти
брюссельських музеїв які беруть участь у
проекті
ми вважаємо що це може бути корисним для
всіх але частина пацієнтів не хотіла йти
тому що вони соромляться виходити на
вулицю і покидати середовище у якому
живуть
але більшість пацієнтів зацікавилася
[музика]
тож Стефан кампіон зараз добровільно йде
в темне місце він запросив нас
добрюсельського музею каналізації
більшість людей не хотіли б зазирати в
каналізацію Як вам від цього стане легше
просто ідея виходу на вулицю щоб
зустрітися з іншими людьми
Я думаю що це цікавий аспект
арт-терапія - це новинка як і
рекомендації пацієнтам з депресією
відвідувати музеї але те що зараз
намагаються зробити в пілотному проекті
зробивши Цю пропозицію фактично рецептом
здається мотивує пацієнта з депресією
дійсно піти і він може взяти з собою до
трьох людей безкоштовно
це може бути дуже важливим кажуть лікарі
щоб допомогти відновити почуття
соціалізації людині яка страждає
психологічно і можливо фінансово
пацієнт може піти самостійно зі своєю
сім'єю і це щось нове для нас і Ми дуже
хочемо спробувати застосувати це на
практиці
проект був започаткований заступницею
мера брюсселя дельфіною Хуба яка чула
про подібні ініціативи в Канаді і
захотіла випробувати об Бельгії
кількість випадків депресії подвоїлася
за 10 років тож це величезна проблема
дуже багато людей страждають ззовні і
можливо всередині ми не знаємо
Так нам нічого втрачати лікарям та
пацієнтам втрачати вже й нічого а для
музею Це просто більша публіки яка
приходить сюди звідси з освітньої
організації охорони здоров'я про понад
900 досліджень підтверджує позитивний
вплив мистецтва на здоров'я пілотний
проєкт завершується в березні але Хуба
Каже що навіть без остаточної статистики
реакція була настільки позитивною що
вона сподівається розширити масштаби
проекту зі мною вже зв'язалися інші
культурні установи а також інші лікарі
які бажають взяти участь у проекті Я
бачу що люди дуже зацікавлені можливо
потрібен час щоб Люди зрозуміли Як це
працює і наважились пройти сюди Але я
думаю що навіть якщо це буде Лише кілька
людей це вже буде дуже позитивно
для деяких відвідувачів це працює навіть
без рецепту
життя таке сумне коли ти бачиш щось
красиве то почуваєшся щасливішим Як на
мене все дуже просто
[музика]
а досвід Стефана кампіона показує що вам
Можливо навіть не потрібно споглядати
щось прекрасне аби підняти собі настрій
Я почуваюся краще Мені дійсно краще
Я забуваю про свою проблему і бачу красу
навколишнього світу
Він каже що з нетерпінням чекає коли
зможе поділитися тим що дізнався з
родиною та друзями що стане ще однією
маленькою перемогою над темрявою
ще один засіб проти самотності та
депресії це любов у на IQ пара яка живе
в Ірландії вони зуміли зберегти іскру
після знайомства майже 20 років тому ще
до того як Цінь Дари сайті знайомство
захопили світ
разом цей чоловік
Віллі дейлі він майстер сватання в
третьому поколінні і легенда цієї
індустрії любовні зв'язки Віллі здобули
йому прихильників по всьому світу
самотні люди З'їжджаються до Маленького
містечка лінз дувана сподіваючись що
Віллі допоможе їм знайти щастя у коханні
що вихідних Віллі дейлі останній
традиційний ірландський сват зустрічає у
цьому барі десятки самотніх людей і він
ніколи не буває тут без своєї книги
кохання потенційних партнерів просять
покласти на неї руки на 7 секунд дехто
шукає На дні келиха трохи більше
сміливості перш ніж заповнити анкету
Віллі щодо свого ідеального партнера
Рене Прилетіла з Торонто Канада
подолавши кілька тисяч кілометрів щоб
зустрітися із Віллі
13 подруг ринепсі вони одружені
скинулися щоб оплатити її поїздку до
майстра сватання
вони планували це три роки а Вони знали
що через три роки Я все ще буду
самотньою тож ми о 14 стрибнули в літак
і ось ми тут намагаємось знайти мені
хлопця десь за океаном по допомогу до
Віллі звертаються десятки самотніх людей
його послуги коштують від 5 до 15 євро
Залежно від настрою часу доби та
кількості випитого Гіннеса
іноді Віллі танцює з кимось зі своїх
клієнток але Все залишається на суто
професійному рівні
Віллі дейлі має дві великі пристрасті
поєднувати у пари самотніх людей і своїх
віслюків коли він був молодшим перед
танцювальним залом можна було побачити
до 28 років якщо хлопець закохувався у
дівчину він привозив її додому верхи на
віслюку але це було дуже давно
люди і досі шукають кохання вони хочуть
щастя
а в сільській Ірландії щастя це діти це
дуже важливо Я знаю одного чоловіка
якому понад 87 років а він все ще хотів
би одружитися і мати дітей віслюки
привернули увагу Сари і Керрі Вони
приїхали сюди на відпочинок зміни соти і
обидві не одружені напередодні ввечері
вони заповнили анкету Віллі а сьогодні
вранці у нього вже були хороші новини
для них обох У мене є два дуже гарних
чоловіків
для тебе я знайшов дуже високого
стрункого темне волосся блакитні очі
зріст приблизно 6 футів 2 дюйми широкі
плечі а його бачили А ти зустрінеш
світловолосого чоловіка з дуже
блакитними не темними очима
і я навіть підозрюю що він можливо
фарбує своє волосся
Але ж ти не проти я теж фарбую волосся
А якщо серйозно То Сара могла б навіть
уявити собі переїзд зі Сполучених Штатів
до Ірландії щоб бути з чоловіком своєї
мрії А те що їх познайомить майстер
сватання додається ідеї чарівності У нас
є багато онлайн можливостей Але я вважаю
що через Інтернет це складніше зробити
тут це просто весело ви дійсно
зустрічайтесь і з кимось у реальному
житті ти бачиш людину І знаєш що це
реальна людина і все таке
Сара та Керрі готуються до зустрічі зі
своїми кавалерами сьогодні ввечері
Віллі розповідає Що йому скоро
виповниться 80 років і він має сімох
дітей від кількох жінок але цей сват у
третьому поколінні не дуже любить
розповідати про себе
про книгу кохання знають Практично всі в
Західній Ірландії навіть його дідусь
випростовував її близько 160 років тому
кажуть що вона поєднувала пари щодо того
як вони вперше зустрілися
це наші леді я вкладу їх з цього боку
з цього боку вони будуть знайомитися між
собою в записнику
[оплески]
гюта Уна магуайра щаслива пара вже 17
років відтоді як квілі витягнув Уно із
танцювального майданчика і вказав на Гю
Це було дуже захоплююче дійсно
захоплююче тому що я була серед купи
людей які шукали собі партнерів і я
побачила Х'ю на танцполі який дуже
смішно танцював і подумала Боже мій ось
той з ким можна повеселитися але
спочатку Уна була дуже холодною із в'ю
він став на одне коліно і зробив
пропозицію ще до закінчення першого
курсу і у на відмовила йому наступного
року він освідчився ще раз і знову у нас
сказала ні
на третій рік я став на два коліна і
вона сказала так
ціла купа людей це було дуже кумедно
вони всі аплодували
там були сотні людей
дуже багато народу
Віллі приніс на зустріч свою книгу
кохання
Уно попросила Гю заплющити очі і
зосередитися вона вважає любовну книгу
своєрідною підзарядкою для їхнього
кохання
один із його синів давно успадкував
ферму але Віллі все що любить
навідуватися сюди тут він фантазує про
те які що пари може звести і знаходить
трохи спокою і тиші
принаймні поки не задзвонить його
телефон
[музика]
сповіщаючи про нове завдання для Віллі
дейлі останнього свата Ірландії
багато хто в пошуках романтики також
вирушають до Парижа міста кохання і саме
зараз воно у повному розквіті так
посеред зими ресторани прикрашають у
Похмурі дні вишуканими квітковими
композиціями що приваблює інфлюенсерів
які шукають місця для фотосесій їхні
публікації у соціальних мережах це
імпульс для бізнесу але як із багатьма
речами в інтернеті реальність дуже
відрізняється від Інстаграму
А я вже думала що пластик виходить із
моди на цьому ми завершуємо нашу
програму цього тижня Дякуємо за перегляд
до зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]